y llegó el momento de hablar de salud de
aquí en directo américa ya está conmigo
en el estudio más romeros a la mar
bienvenida a félix martes y feliz mañana
empiezan entonces a aparecer los
estudios que relacionarían las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 a los cambios en el
ciclo menstrual nosotros incluso hicimos
una encuesta en las redes sociales del
año pasado y muchas mujeres escribieron
al respecto omar pues sí precisamente
hablamos de eso porque es una de las
grandes deudas que tiene la ciencia y la
investigación alrededor de las vacunas
pues porque nunca se investigó si
realmente esto podía ser un efecto
secundario nunca se preguntó en los
estudios sobre la seguridad de la vacuna
ahora a raíz de balas denuncias de
varias mujeres empiezan a salir estos
datos y empiezan a salir estos primeros
estudios que nos confirman que podría
ser realmente real que las vacunas
contra convencionales tengan un efecto
sobre el ciclo menstrual el estudio más
reciente es de la universidad de
extremadura en españa' y algo muy
significativo es que la muestra que uso
es de 17 mil quinientas mujeres son
muchas mujeres que respondieron de las
cuales prácticamente la mitad un 46%
dijo haber notado cambios en la de su
ciclo menstrual también un 44% dijo
haber notado cambios en el flujo
menstrual también es muy importante
tener en cuenta que este estudio todavía
son resultados preliminares que no ha
sido revisado por pares por el resto de
la comunidad científica y que falta
todavía investigar cuáles son las causas
de esta relación pero pues nos empieza a
dar señales de que efectivamente hay
algo que investigar y hay algo que es
saber ahí hay otro estudio que apareció
a inicios de este mes este sí ha estado
revisado por pares se hizo por varios en
universidades estadounidenses y también
llegó a la conclusión de que después de
la vacunación hay varias mujeres que
notaron a cambios que pueden deberse
precisamente a las vacunas contra el
commit 19 escuchemos lo que dicen las
conclusiones de este estudio
encontramos diferencias estadísticamente
significativas
entre vacunadas y no vacunadas pero el
cambio en el ciclo menstrual fue de
menos de un día a un subgrupo de
personas que recibió dos dosis en un
solo ciclo tubo de media un incremento
de dos días en la duración de su ciclo
aunque aproximadamente un 10% de estas
personas experimentaron un cambio de 8
días o más este cambio se atenuó después
de dos ciclos es decir raúl que al final
la gran conclusión es que si puede haber
estos cambios aunque se asocian a
cambios menores y que vuelven a la
normalidad al cabo de poco tiempo pero
igual que sabemos que nos puede dar
fiebre o que nos puede doler la cabeza
también tenemos que saber que las
vacunas nos pueden provocar cambios en
nuestro ciclo definitivamente algo está
pasando con eso marc y bueno pues
también a mí particularmente la vacunas
me dio un poco de taquicardia como unas
semanas después que me la pusieron y ya
todo normal pero seguimos hablando de
las vacunas contra el cob y 19 que
realmente son buenas y funcionan y pues
el llamado es a cuidarnos en israel
siguen ofreciendo la cuarta dosis a
pesar de que uno estudio preliminar lo
ve suficiente ventajas no les es
suficiente ventajas y ahí está un poco
el debate también alrededor de cuántas
vacunas nos vamos a tener que poner
estas cuartas dosis que también pueden
ser las segundas dosis de refuerzo ya
nos hacemos un lío con los números en
israel la están empezando a aplicar para
tratar de frenar estas oleadas de
omicron que están afectando
prácticamente a todos los los países sin
embargo hay un hospital israelí que
decidió ver los efectos de esta cuarta
vacuna con su propio personal y las
conclusiones a las que llegaron fue que
si hay un aumento de anticuerpos pero
pueden no ser significativo para frenar
el contagio con la variante o micro en
esto es lo que decía una de las
investigadores principales del estudio
creo que la decisión de permitir una
cuarta vacuna a la población vulnerable
es correcta puede dar un pequeño
beneficio
pero probablemente no es suficiente para
permitirla a la población general
porque un adicional windscheif sin
embargo a pesar de estos resultados
siguen administrándose esas cuartas
dosis cuando todavía sabemos que hay
mucha parte del mundo que no tiene
acceso ni siquiera a la pauta de la
vacunación entonces pues tendremos que
ver si realmente es necesario para la
población general o si se está
exagerando muy bien también como lo
decía el doctor oscar franco el día de
ayer perdón cargarles pérez y marc y
usted me corrige lo tenemos mañana a
oscar franco que decía que más bien
debemos ver una vacuna que sí impida el
contagio de colitis y me porque sabemos
que con las actuales pues las personas
se pueden contagiar y que puedan ser
flexibles sobre todo para también varios
tipos de variantes porque pueden surgir
nuevas en el futuro en básicas vamos a
ver entonces qué pasa el desarrollo de
estas vacunas contra el coi 19 las
polémicas vacunas y terminamos con los
últimos avances en la investigación
sobre la esclerosis múltiple pues sí es
un estudio que se publicó la semana
pasada y que básicamente lleva a
concluir que tener el virus un virus
llamado el virus de epstein-barr puede
multiplicar hasta por 30 el riesgo de
después desarrollar esclerosis múltiple
como ven en estas cifras es algo que
puede ser algo intrigante porque este
virus que también es el que provoca la
mononucleosis puede ser muy común el 95%
de la población lo tiene no contraemos
en la adolescencia o en los primeros
años de juventud sin embargo riesgo de
desarrollar esclerosis múltiple solo del
0 5 % sin embargo los datos de este
estudio son bastante concluyentes que
hay una correlación entre ambas cosas
aunque deberemos seguir investigando
porque no puede ser algún otro factor de
riesgo tiene que haber algún alguna cosa
que desencadene que este virus provoque
esta enfermedad porque es importante
saber esto pues porque la esclerosis
múltiple sigue siendo una enfermedad que
no tiene cura y saber que este virus
está en el origen de esta dolencia puede
ayudar a provocar a desarrollar nuevas
maneras de prevenirlo por ejemplo una
vacuna que prevenga contra el contagio
de este tipo de virus raúl gracias mal
entonces por toda la información acerca
de nuestra salud lo que nos importa en
términos de salud y mañana somos con más
información al respecto nosotros vamos
ahora a hablar con esta segunda mitad
del día